Ukraine's long counter-offensive for her
son grinds on but despite Russia's
recent order to evacuate civilians and
reports of some military drawback the
message from Ukraine is that the
Russians are digging in for a fight
they're changing positions our
intelligence confirmed that they have
been reinforced by very many recruits
they are strengthening their flanks they
dig up trenches because they fear our
Air Force fear our artillery and
soldiers
destroyed Russian armor tells the tale
of Ukrainian gains the Russian general
in charge of this war recently talked of
difficult decisions having to be made
around her son attracting speculation
that Ukraine might soon retake it in
time for winter
but Ukraine is now talking about Russian
reinforcements and obstacles to progress
the situation on the front line itself
is very tense the enemy has dug itself
in and at the moment it seems they do
not intend to leave it is noticeable
that they work to reinforce their
dugouts trenches and fortifications away
from Ukraine Russia's armed forces were
carrying out exercises on Wednesday
simulating coordinated use of nuclear
weapons launched from land sea and air
the Russian military says it's in
preparation for a response to an enemy
attack Russia's president making more
unsubstantiated claims about a nuclear
threat from Ukraine including a
radiological or dirty bomb
they ignore the statements of the key of
regime about the desire to get nuclear
weapons after all the key authorities
said that openly no everyone is keeping
quiet there are also plans to use the
so-called dirty bomb for provocations
Russia's State media is amplifying such
claims still further saying that Ukraine
intends to put a dirty bomb inside a
fake Russian missile and detonate it
over Chernobyl at every turn such
accusations have been dismissed by
Ukraine and its allies as absurd
dangerous transparently false either
escalatory Russian grandstanding or an
indication that Russia itself intends to
use such a device but Conventional
Weapons continue to do damage enough
here in denipro a petrol station set
Ablaze by a Russian strike emergency
crews said two people including a
pregnant woman were killed Harry Fawcett
Al Jazeera Kiev